[Music]
vaccinations have been top of mind for
many and our four-legged friends are no
different illnesses like canine flu can
be serious but also can be prevented it
is a virus spread dog to dog through
things like water bowls toys even
barking the chief vet at the animal
foundation says while she has not seen a
spike here in the valley canine
influenza can mimic other respiratory
illnesses so pet parents should be aware
of the risk there's animals that are
asymptomatic when they're carrying
influenza so there could be no signs
things like fever coughing um
nasal discharge
being lethargic
all the way up to severe signs of
pneumonia and even death
dr jared says it's like the human flu
but don't worry there's no documented
cases of it spreading from dog to human
as for the treatment she says it's
supportive care because secondary
infections are the concern the best way
to prevent it a two dose vaccine with an
annual booster
so if your lifestyle your pet
warrants the vaccine you should get it
um
you know it's just a silly thing to to
risk if there's a way to prevent it dr
jared says most vet offices in the
valley have the vaccine available